con el resurgimiento de la epidemia de
covid en China la preocupación ha
aumentado en el país asiático
principalmente en los adultos mayores
que son las primeras Víctimas de la
Nueva Ola que golpea el país por eso las
autoridades redoblan sus esfuerzos para
que se vacunen aunque no todos están
dispuestos a hacerlo
no no me vacuné solo uso una máscara y
tengo todo mi equipo en mi bolso pero
tengo miedo de las agujas
escuchamos mucho sobre los efectos
secundarios de las vacunas conozco a
alguien que tuvo fiebre después de la
inyección Y luego coágulos de sangre
personalmente Prefiero esperar no
estamos seguros de la eficacia de las
vacunas el virus sigue mutando Cómo
sabemos que siguen siendo útiles
pero mientras la población se cuestiona
los hospitales ya no dan abasto como se
puede ver en esta unidad de cuidados
intensivos en Beijing aquí el personal
informa sobre un incremento comparable a
los inicios de la pandemia en el 2020
tenemos que atender más de 530
emergencias todos los días los pacientes
tienen niveles de oxigenación en sangre
muy bajos entre 50 y el 70%, lo que los
convierte en casos muy graves
una ola de contagios que llega apenas
una semanas después de la
flexibilización de las restricciones
sanitarias por parte del gobierno de
shijing Pink aunque sólo han reportado
dos fallecimientos los expertos estiman
que alrededor de 5.000 personas mueren
todos los días a causa del covid-19 en
el país por este rebrote